we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
i did this story yesterday about how
jordan peterson attacked me for a video
i did about him i got a voicemail about
that let's listen to the voicemail then
we'll talk about it
hey david dale from denver again um just
calling regarding the jordan peterson uh
clip you put on youtube yes uh the
question i would ask dr peterson is
you think it's bad to demoralize them
and by telling them the truth and the
reality of what's going on
but is that actually better to lie to
them about that than it is
to tell them the truth so they can face
the truth and
maybe come up with a solution yeah i
mean listen this is basically the point
i made
jordan peterson wept
because he felt today's youth are being
demoralized and their lives are being
ruined by being told
as humans we're up against some hard
problems and one of those problems is
um
climate change caused by
industrialization burning of fossil
fuels and human activity on planet earth
jordan peterson says it's demoralizing
to tell young people that and they're
almost being told peterson claims that
they are morally bad because these are
problems that we're facing my view is it
would be immoral not to tell them that
if we want to solve these problems to
some degree
young people are going to be the people
that when they are not so young are
going to be in a position hopefully to
solve some of the problems that we're
dealing with if we hide the fact that
these problems exist from them how are
we doing them a service we're doing them
a disservice i would argue and that's uh
i i believe that's what the caller is
arguing here as well i agree with the
caller i disagree with jordan peterson
jordan peterson as i told you yesterday
after flipping out on me said that an
overweight woman is ugly and then quit
twitter
so it was a wild week on twitter for
jordan peterson we have a great bonus
show for you today
here's a fascinating study that was done
americans who do not currently have
student loan debt were asked
do you support joe biden for giving the
student debt of people who do have debt
and overwhelmingly those without student
debt said yes i still am in favor of
that i don't have student debt and i'm
in favor of it and i'll explain to you
why on the bonus show secondly u.s
soccer has agreed to an equal pay deal
for the men's and women's players very
interesting we'll talk about it and
there's a lot to discuss related to it
and for those of you who remember martin
shkreli martin shkreli is this sort of
uh
dark figure
who is mostly known for buying a
pharmaceutical company and then
exploding the cost of the drug that the
pharmaceutical company
manufactures he actually was just
released from prison not related to that
but related to some financial crimes
that he uh was convicted of he has now
been released from prison and we will
talk about the hero's welcome that he's
getting in some places not everywhere
though all of those stories on today's
bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com to get instant access and
remember that on monday memorial day
we'll be doing a one-day membership
special trying to bring in as many new
members in one day as we can
if you'd like to be notified when that
membership discount is live
just sign up for my newsletter the
newsletter is free at davidpakman.com
and you'll hear from me on memorial day
with very specific instructions and of
course
everybody who signs up gets access to
the bonus show oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad right okay we'll see everybody on
the bonus show or tomorrow